you developed a more efficient slower a
style that you could continue for five
months yeah and you just end up it's
like moving meditation it just became
like you know the limiting factor was
just like I was just getting bored I
wasn't actually breathing what were you
thinking of this is the thing I mean you
had to any given time any tide you had
to think of something that was going to
be more powerful than the thought of
stopping or fatigue or CEO else's like
deeper into your skin and so sometimes
it was real easy because you were
swimming with dolphins minke whales
that's one with a basking shark did they
come over to you go yeah brilliant yeah
there's a video of ages ago with the the
minke whale and the house for 12 hours
across the Bristol Channel so that's
kind of England to Wales and this was
without doubt for all the hardship that
I've spoke about I just want to say that
there was some amazing moments this one
particular moment swimming across the
the Bristol Channel and all of a sudden
minke whale kind of big as this table
breeches right next to me I was like
whoa like Thomas Rhys I turned to map
the captain I was like man am i safe
like what's going on like should I get
out the warranty said no no no you're
absolutely fine and I was like is he's a
minke whale that they find the friendly
I was like okay fair enough so I keep
swimming and then for the next five
miles the minke whale was circling me it
was breaching over the top it was coming
under me and swimming like that well I
turned him out I said like matter what's
going on and he said I've never seen
this he's been sailing like 40 years he
says I've never seen this he said but
what I think is happening is I think
it's a female and I trying to [ __ ] you
well I said it's not mating season is
like a spy it's fine again what I think
having you for later four months in this
water I'm gonna [ __ ] it mating season
is probably right around the corner
she's like if he sticks around
so I know I always like you know what
that was a concern of mine that was a
bet no Matt said no no I think it's a
female I think that she thinks that
you're an injured seal and so for the
next five miles
she basically guided me all the way to
the shallower water Wow and as I got
there it was literally the depth of the
water matt said yep yeah much shallower
water and we turned whale breached one
more time and then and then swam off as
if to say you know you're safe now
Wow amazing that's incredible amazing
yeah so for all of the hardship and
everything that I described there were
moments and sunsets and and swimming
with seals and and it was amazing whoa
so that's the basking shark is that what
you encountered yeah so that was in
that's the actual one you encountered I
don't know if I can't I mean I'll swim
boss seems like you could swim in there
I was I was concerned about that one but
they know so that's a basking shark
they're friendly right the Matt can you
imagine seeing that like yes swimming
free Scotland not mountains either side
of you and so so to your point about
asking what you think about it's very
easy to swim when when you know there's
dolphins and everything but there's
times when you are lost in this moving
meditation but then you see something
like that and you very quickly got to
get your wits about you yeah
because because there were killer whales
as well up you know coming from sort of
Iceland around the top of of Scotland so
that was that was a concern were they
interested in knew what thankfully we
didn't see any but they wouldn't attack
you or anything well so this is it so we
were speaking with marine biologist at
the time saying look like what's what's
the situation here and they said well
you know what's really interesting
they're so intelligent you know killer
whales are so intelligent and they've
never been known this was what they said
to me they've never been known in in the
wild to attack a human and I said okay
fantastic
and they said however if they're gonna
attack a human it's probably going to be
you because no one's ever spent that
amount of time in the water as well you
know so I was like right they said all
you need to do company so they just said
look all you need to do is make sure
that you don't look like a seal because
they might mistake you for a seal but
they might bite you
but then they will go oh whoa that that
intelligent that below oh that doesn't
taste like a seal so they might you know
so I was just trying my best not to look
like a seal well I think when they've
attacked people in the wild though it's
always in them in captivity it's always
been trainers yeah it's been angered
frustration yeah you know and that was
my experience with the minke whale after
me it was people said like how do you
swim at night because certainly around
west of Scotland it was a depth of 200
meters so you just you can't you don't
know what's under you so there was that
element but but I think having swum with
the minke well around the Bristol
Channel I was very aware that in the
hierarchy of the sea I was very low down
the pecking order and and if it's
comforting in any strange way I was like
look if I was gonna be eaten I'll be
eaten in the day just as much as I'll be
eaten at night right you know it's just
it's just one of those just darkness
yeah yeah just like you can't you can't
see the hand in front of your face it's
like the more ether for instance we were
40 Mars away from land and this kind of
cutting across this huge Bay across the
top of Scotland and you know it was
clouded over so there was no thick you
couldn't even see anything because there
was no moonlight or no stars and it was
you in that complete sensory deprivation
you can hear everything and it's just if
you hear a noise a rip or like I really
hope that's not a killer whale but they
know you've then got six hours to
contemplate more it's so it's this and
again like I said Marcus Aurelius
meditations stoic philosophy that the
conversations you have in your own head
are just as powerful other people and I
certainly found that all the way around
that you just those times when you saw
what am i doing out here like seriously
and that comes from I think you know
this this idea of you have to be doing
it for the right reasons